hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
I have made plenty of videos with Tesla
in it or about Tesla like before I got
one before you know back when it's my
dream car it's something I've wanted a
lot I've done a factory tour I got to
test drive them I talked about all the
tech in them and then I really wanted it
now that I have one I've continued to
make a bunch of videos about so Tesla's
great and they've been really great to
me but Tesla's are obviously not perfect
one of the biggest complaints especially
like among owners and people who drive
the cars especially because it's a car
company and the car industry is very
very old is maintenance Tesla has had
noted maintenance and quality control
issues because there's such a young
company they don't have quite the
manufacturing prowess that these super
old companies do but the tolerances get
tighter with time and they just don't
have that amount of time yet so whether
it's like alignment issues on the
crazy-complicated Falcon wing doors and
the Model X or just little things like
chrome misalignment or loose cables or
string which is little things that
rattle small problems happen like a lot
in Tesla's it seems because their
manufacturing tolerances aren't as tight
and they're just not as good with
quality control but recently I've been
having much more serious problems with
my car Apollo that I've been making
videos about and since I'm making videos
about the experience of owning it
figured I might as well include this
experience and all that so Apollo as you
guys probably remember it was one of the
first P 100 DS off the assembly line in
around September this year very very
early in production and I've used it and
driven it a lot I put about 5800 miles
on it in the last three months or so so
I'm more than most people drive and
mostly because I love it like I find
excuses to drive it other give people
rides places or if I have like
Thanksgiving in Virginia this year
instead of New Jersey I'll just do a
road trip or have I play Ultimate
Frisbee so I have I'm playing for the
pro team based out of Philadelphia now
so that's a long drive a couple times a
week so I'm driving it a lot so on day
five of owning the car with less than a
couple hundred miles on it's basically
still brand new I'm going to a nearby
destination near my home and one of the
turns near the destination I go to make
a left-hand turn and halfway into the
turn as I'm going across traffic the
power steering essentially stops working
so the wheel is straight and I have to
like
really pull out the wheel to complete
the left-hand turn so I get out of the
turn and then everything's fine again
and power steering's back on and I'm
like ok I was kind of weird and I'm
still obviously new to Tesla so I kind
of thought it was like one of the
sensors malfunctioning I've had it like
tweaked a little bit to get me out of
the way of the potential collision when
I'm on the highway someone drifts into
my lane it does the shimmy for me so I
thought it was like a weird malfunction
of that so I'm like okay I keep driving
I get to the destination and turning
into the parking lot of that destination
it happens again I'm turning left across
traffic halfway into the turn it locks
up I really have to pull the steering
wheel to get in again so at that point
I'm like okay that's weird
I pull to the back of the parking lot
and I have it towed to the service
center because I don't want to drive it
again and it takes some 12 days to
determine they need to replace the
steering rack so they do that I get the
car back and we're good to go so five
thousand eight hundred glorious miles
later it reappears it rears its ugly
head I'm driving this time on I'm
getting into a little bit of a bigger
intersection turning onto a highway
across traffic making a left and it
freezes again this time there was a car
next to me and if that car had also been
making a left I would have gone straight
into its path luckily they continued
straight I pulled to the side lane it
fixed itself and I continued along but
now I'm like okay that's happened before
I know that's a problem that's dangerous
I go home I it happens two more times
before I get home and when I get home I
pull into a nearby parking lot again I
just have it towed again because I don't
want to drive to the service center
again so that was like two days ago and
now the car has been sitting at the
service center that's the last time I
drove it and now I'm currently waiting
to hear back from them to see what is
wrong again whoo there's a different
solution to the problem now because they
replace the steering rack and that
didn't help so now they need to fix it
again so that's that's a lot to happen
to a new car a new expensive car at that
in the first couple thousand miles of
owning it as you can tell this I guess
you now know this isn't my car this is a
loaner Tesla gives me and that's not
because it's me they do this that's
pretty standard treatment the high-end
car manufacturer will give you a loaner
of your car or a better one that they
have while you wait for your car to
finish service but apparently when you
have a recurring issue something happens
like the same issue more than once
Tesla sort of escalates the priority of
reissues so there is an engineer flying
from California to New Jersey to look at
Apollo specifically to fix this issue
now obviously different people will have
different reactions to this to a lot of
people it's like okay you know you'll be
fine they're taking care of you they are
aware of the issue they escalated it
that's what they should do you have a
loner you're fine
but other people it's like it sounds
like you're beta testing this car and I
get that like a lot of people were set
like I tweeted about the second issue
the second time it happened and a lot of
people are like man that's a lot of
problems to have with a car so early in
it when it's so high-end you should
return it and just get a different one
so I'm going to give them another chance
to repair this car and I guess that's
where we're at right now is I'm just
gonna keep letting them try to fix it
but again if they try to fix it now and
everything goes great and they find the
problem they diagnose it they replace a
part and we're good and it never comes
back then we're clean Apollo's good as
new but if it comes back again then
that's like strike three and we got to
do something bad so I guess my question
to you is this if a car is in your
opinion the best car on the road in
between issues but it has big issues
like every couple months is it really
worth it anymore
like not even an electric not even if
it's a Tesla think of your dream car if
you're a dream car the one you have in
mind right now had problems every couple
months you finally got it and it's just
having these issues do you just scrap it
you just move on it's my question let me
know what you guys think thanks for
watching Toxie guys the next one maybe
follow me on Twitter if you guys are
interested in seeing the updates and
seeing what happens with Apollo if she
gets fixed or not thanks for watching
talk to you guys the next one peace
[Music]